welcome back well i'm now going to do um
well probably just a bunch of
integration by parts problems well as
many as i can do in 10 minutes without
confusing you so let me just write the
formula for integration by parts and if
you ever forget it i mean it doesn't
hurt to memorize it but if you ever
forget it you just really have to just
derive it from the product rule the of
differentiation but it just says that if
we have an integral
of
f of x
times g prime of x right so if you see
within the integral sign you see one
function and then you see the derivative
of another function
and i think with practice this is
integration by parts is really a bit of
an art it's not kind of systematic
that's g prime of x that equals f of x
times g of x
right this is how it's the product rule
in reverse
minus
the integral of the derivative of the
first function
f prime of x
times the second function right and it's
kind of easy to memorize because there's
this symmetry to the formula
d of x so let's see if we can apply this
and really once you know that you should
use integration by parts i think you'll
find that it's not that hard to do it
the hard part is to recognize when you
should use integration by parts from my
point of view it's kind of my last
resort or
once you have a lot of practice you
might recognize well if there's an e to
the x in it or if there's a trig
function in it and i can't do the
reverse chain i can't do the reverse
chain rule or integration by
substitution then integration by parts
is probably my best
option assuming i'm seeing this on an
exam and not in real life in real life
it might be an unsolvable integral and
you'd have to use a computer or some
other uh technique but if you're singing
on an exam you know it's a solvable
integral and if you can't solve it any
other way it's probably integration by
parts
but uh let's just do some problems let's
say i want to take the integral of
x squared
e to the x
dx
so if i saw this out of the blue and i
didn't know that this was a presentation
on the integration by parts i would you
know at first clearly this isn't a
polynomial so i can't just do the kind
of simple polynomial anti-derivative
then i would try to see well is is there
the is there the derivative of something
that i
you know of one function
of kind of a composite function here so
i can do the reverse chain rule let's
see the derivative of x here's one so no
i can't do anything here so i use the
chain rule
and the way i think about the chain rule
is
i want to simplify it right so when i go
into this term right here i'm going to
have to i have to pick up my f of x i
have to pick my f of x out of probably
one of these two functions so that the f
prime of x is simpler
right and i need to pick my
my g prime of x
right
either you know i would guess that
either x squared is going to be my g
prime of x or
e of x e to the x is going to be my g
prime of x and i want to pick that so
that when i take the antiderivative of
it it's going to be simpler or at least
not more complicated well i know that if
i take the derivative of x squared that
simplifies it and i also know that the
and once again this is one of my to me a
very mind-blowing
idea but the anti-derivative of e to the
x is e to the x
so it's probably a good idea to say that
f of x is equal to it's probably let me
let me change colors it's probably a
good idea to make f of x is equal to x
squared because later i'm going to take
the derivative of it and the derivative
of it simplifies it it's probably a good
idea to make g prime of x
e to the x because later i'm going to
take the anti-derivative of it and the
anti-derivative of the x is e to the x
it's not going to become any more
complicated
so if we assume if what i'm doing is
right
then what did we say well here we just
multiply the two
the the the real functions right so
when i say the real functions i mean
kind of not the derivatives of either
one of them so we f of x we're saying f
of x is x squared
let me let me i'm trying to stay color
consistent x squared
and we said g of x now don't get
confused we're saying g prime of x let
me let me write it in a little corner
down here we're saying that g prime of x
is equal to e to the x
and of course if g prime of x is equal
to e x then g of x is also equal to e to
e to the x right
so g of x i don't want you to think that
i'm somehow putting g prime of x here
i'm actually i've taken the
anti-derivative it just happens to be
the same function
as e to the x
and then from that
we subtract
the integral we take the derivative of x
squared
so you get 2x
right
and then times
the antiderivative
of g prime of x well
g prime of x is e to the x you take the
anti-derivative well it's still e to the
x right
actually i should probably stay let me
keep the colors kind of consistent so
you know what i'm
hopefully doing
e to the x
the example using e to the x might be a
little complicated because it's hard to
tell whether i've taken the derivative
or not and you can kind of keep
reverting back to the top formula if you
get confused
let me pick this color
dx
so it looks like i've simplified it a
little bit this
integral
looks easier to solve than this integral
but once again when i look at this i'm
like well how do i solve this i can't
use the integration by substitution
right because
there's not like i have a embedded
function and i have the derivative of it
sitting right next to it so
maybe i need to do integration by parts
again
so let's do that so let's say let me let
me do it separately um well let's let's
just let's assume i think you're getting
a little bit of the hang of it along the
same vein that this is f of x
that this is f of x and that this is g
prime of x now right we're kind of we're
doing integration by parts within
integration by parts so if that is the
case
that this this integral is going to
equal right because we have the minus
sign out front
right this minus sign out front
this integral is going to equal f of x
times g of x our f of x is just 2x
our g of x this is g prime of x now
right remember we're kind of doing a new
problem within the original big problem
so this is g prime of x but g of x is
still just e of x right i took the
anti-derivative of it
and that's minus
the integral
the integral of the derivative of the
first function
right f prime of x
so that's just 2
and then the anti-derivative
of the second function well that's easy
the anti-derivative of u the x is just e
to the x
interesting
now i think you see where we're going
this this is actually let me write the
whole thing right because this is x
squared
e to the x just so we don't lose track
of our original problem
interesting now i think we have an
integral that is pretty straightforward
to solve right oh no don't want to
forget my dxs
what's the integral of
we could we could take this 2 out of
this right and i think it becomes pretty
obvious what's the integral of e to the
x this is a scratch out this says dx
just so and it's a little messy i don't
like this color
magenta
well the integral of e to the x is the
or the the anti-derivative of e to the x
is e to the x right so let's write that
so i'm going to rewrite everything we've
done so this x squared
e to the x
minus
minus 2 x
e to the x
right and then this minus you distribute
it so it becomes a plus so then it's
plus
right i just took the minus i multiplied
it times this minus so i got a plus 2.
and then the anti-derivative e to the x
is just e to the
x and then of course we should never
forget the plus c
pretty fancy no
let's see we figured out
the anti-derivative or the indefinite
integral of x squared e to the x is this
big fancy thing i bet you before
listening to this video you would never
imagine that you could tackle
integration like like this and you know
you i i you could actually try x to the
n times e to the x you could try x to
the tenth times d x and actually turns
out you'll just have to do this many
many many many times but every time you
do integration by parts that the
exponent on the
x term just becomes smaller and smaller
and smaller until you get to something
that's really easy to integrate and then
you can do it and you'll have kind of
this big long expression
it might be tedious it might be hairy
but at least you have a tool kit or you
have something in your tool kit that you
can tackle
integral problems like this
i'll probably do one more video on
integration by brushes because i think
this is one of the harder
concepts to to really grasp and feel
comfortable with
and then i'll i'll try to do a bunch of
bunch of examples maybe not soon but in
the next couple of weeks on just a lot
of integration and i'm going to mix it
up so that hopefully you can get a sense
of how
i try to figure out which of my
integration tools i should use for a
certain problem when i see the problem
see in the next presentation